welcome the best life 30 your 30 day
journey to creating the best life
possible for yourself you can just watch
this video or if you want to sign up for
the entire series for free and get the
bonus companion worksheets that go with
this video check the link in the
description below alright today is day 3
and we're going to learn how to find our
values so the infinite game exists up
here finite game exists down here
alright the infinite game this will
includes the Y what I call our purpose
cause or belief it's the vision of the
company it's where we're going it's
something that we will never practically
reach in our lifetimes or ever but we
will die trying that's the point right
it's different from a big hairy
audacious goal which for all practical
purposes you could reach it may be
difficult but you could reach it this is
an ideal something it's a vision of the
worlds of my vision I imagine a world in
which the vast majority of people wake
up every single morning inspired to go
to work feel safe when they're there and
return home fulfilled at the end of the
day that is my vision right we will
never practically that get there but we
will die trying the United States was
founded with a document called the
Declaration of Independence in which the
document stated all men are created
equal now the United States has not
achieved that and will never achieve
that but it the country is at its best
when we're trying to achieve that civil
rights women's suffrage gay rights the
you know universal education universal
health care etc etc this is where our
values exist our values are timeless
they do not change every year whenever
we have a strategic off-site and if they
do you have a problem that happens in
big companies every few years a new CEO
comes in and I have a values thing and
they change it and they change and they
change no no your values are your values
right and they're based on your founders
and they exist from patterns of how you
operate when you are operating at your
natural best when your company is
operating at its natural best when all
cylinders are firing when you're in the
flow whatever euphemism you want to use
there is a pattern that emerges and that
pattern are your values there's a
minimum of
three there's no more than five if
there's more than five there's usually
redundancy you can find overlap that you
can find lowest common denominators and
they are intractable these things are
inherently intangible and hard to
measure right which is why they often
get brushed aside it's not that they
don't exist they're just hard to measure
then down here you have the finance what
I call the what it's all the tangible
stuff right things like our interests
exist down here because they are
tangible they are inherently easy to see
and easy to measure like products sold
money taken in things like that right
number of clients we have the way you
build an infinite business is you want
to run all decisions first through your
values and your cause and then through
your interests that's how it works step
number two in the process of structuring
or creating this world-class life your
five non-negotiable values really
important to look at your values what
are values values are what your going to
value as you go through your days as you
go through your weeks as you go through
your life values could be what a mine I
value beauty so I want to be around
beauty as much as possible I love art
galleries I love nature I love sunset I
love looking at the Stars I love
beautiful food simply prepared with
people who I love I love beautiful
conversations I love beautiful books
because a home with a large library is a
wonderful home to be in so step number
two in this process to set yourself up
for a spectacular life what are your
five non-negotiables alleys maybe it's
you'll be around beauty everyday maybe
it's no matter what the situation is I
will always live with integrity maybe
one of your non-negotiable values will
be I will exercise even what I don't
feel like it maybe one of your
non-negotiable values will be family
first I don't know these are just some
things that I want you to think about if
you're familiar with my work you know
for the last 34 years I've been just
obsessed
so with wanting to know what makes the
difference and equality people's lives
why is it so many people have big dreams
but such a small number of people ever
make those dreams a reality and for
those that do make it a reality what is
it gets them not only to follow through
but then to enjoy what they have I don't
know if you've ever had the experience
of achieving something that you've
always wanted and then afterwards
thinking to yourself is this all there
is that's one of the worst feelings are
worse it's almost worse than than
failing because when you fail at least
you know hey I can still find a way to
make it happen but when you succeed and
you're not happy you're not fulfilled
then you got a real problem there's two
things that control everything in your
life every thought every feeling every
emotion every action you have in your
life what you're wearing today whether
you're gonna turn this off within a few
minutes or whether you're gonna stick
with me here for two or three minutes
it's all controlled by two things your
beliefs and your values whatever you
believe if you think life is just a
waste of time doesn't matter what you do
or you know you're big-boned then
obviously you're not gonna go for it
you're not gonna try to lose weight
you're not gonna go push for that next
level of your career or your finances or
or your relationship or anything else
beliefs control us but so do our values
some people you know value just kicking
back some people value making it happen
some people value their family the most
some people value love but you know the
real challenge is we have values in
conflict when you really want to make a
difference in the world or you really
want to do well for your family or you
really want to do well financially but
simultaneously you know you don't want
upset anybody you want to be totally
honest you want to make everybody happy
when we have conflicts between what we
want and what we think we can have or
you know you have a goal of what you
really want to make happen but then you
have this other belief inside that says
this damn stuff never does work those
inner conflicts are what keep people
from using all of their energy it's kind
of like taking two steps forward and
three steps back used to be people kind
of ran on kind of seven-year cycles it's
kind of an arbitrary number but think
about it from 17 to 24 is kind of a
stage of life for a lot of people from
24 really till about 31
that's another stage of life 32 to 39 or
40 years old in other stage 40 to 47
stage and those are random numbers but
what I mean is people tend have an idea
but they think life's about it's my kids
it's building my business it's making
money it's god it's family it's whatever
it is and then they've go for it for a
period of time three four five six seven
years whatever maybe ten but then
there's a time in which people begin to
question they begin to look at their
life and they begin to say is this
really what I want have you found
yourself with that at any time and then
they do one of two things
they either recommit and they go for
another seven years and they take it to
another level
or they make a strategic decision that
shifts the direction of their life
either way your decisions control your
destiny and if you don't choose that's a
choice as well some people just kind of
stay in the middle in that lukewarm
place not shirring what not sure what
they really want so this is kind of off
the cuff what I'm really trying to say
to you is maybe the question asked is
weird I want my life to be today and
where am I really going what is my
destiny what's gonna fill me up what's
gonna give me the meaning for my life
that's gonna give me joy in my life not
just achieved but but real enjoyment a
sense of meaning and aliveness I
absolutely know I will be the greatest
entrepreneur of this era because I'm
gonna win on the two fronts that people
gonna judge by I'll make enough money so
that I'm in the conversation and I will
inspire and help more entrepreneurs than
the rest of the field combined I'm
talking to all of them because what Elon
Musk does in his actions to inspire is
incredible
it's incredible and Steve Jobs and then
but what I'm doing is different and I
know it the end because and by the way
it's cuz I want it more something I'm
better I just want that that's the part
I want I'm it's what this whole thing is
that's why the document like people
don't even understand what I'm actually
doing that I'm leaving so much like from
a businessman see but I'm leaning so
much money on the table but money's not
to go no you know what's funny for me
money stop being a goal at $100,000 I
couldn't believe I made a hundred
thousand dollars a year I was like that
was it and since then nothing's been the
same doesn't feel the same not a million
not a million
doesn't feel the same hundred thousand
is it ever okay to violate core values
to achieve a goal okay so first of all
really obvious your values and your
goals should be aligned they should not
be adversarial they shouldn't be counter
to each other and if you think about
what your goals are your goals should be
set up in a way that they support your
values and vice versa that's just the
way it is so I'm not sure where this is
gonna be an issue if you're setting up
goals that are contrary to your values
you've got some issues now I guess if
you had the goal of winning the blue
belt jiu-jitsu championships and in
order to win you you cheated like you
claimed someone was reaping your leg and
use it on you tap and you get the guy
who qualified and you win that's could
be an example right yeah now do I
support that no you know that's wrong
you you don't win against the values of
actually the values of martial arts to
do that so you didn't win anything and
you didn't achieve your goal because you
weren't actually the best so I say no on
that one uh another one let's say you
wanted to make a certain level of profit
at your company so you cheated a little
bit on the quality of the manufacturing
and you sold items that weren't quite
reliable do I support that no right for
animal and why let me tell you why
because your goal your goal is not even
aligned with your goal itself because
when you start making substandard
manufactured items what's gonna happen
in the long run keep it going to say we
don't like these yeah we're not gonna
buy them anymore
so you didn't win you might have wanted
the short term but you didn't win and
and again you're going against your
value you should have values that you
don't want to you know take profit over
making good product and again in the
long run that value is gonna cost you
right people aren't gonna want to buy
your product anymore we do so many
different things so this is the question
I sighs get how can you do so many
different things why don't you stick to
the knitting the kind of traditional
advice would be to stay focused and keep
the business
and I the way I think about this is we
actually do stick to one thing it's just
not described it something the business
is so if we do Web Services which is you
know big enterprise is buying compute
services from us and we have our retail
business and we have Amazon Studios
which is making original content Amazon
God the things you listed so but the
cultural thread that runs through all
these things is the same we only have a
few principles of the Amazon kind of
core values that we go back to over and
over again and if you looked at each of
the things that we do you would see
those run straight through everything so
the first one and by far the most
important one is customer obsession and
we talk about it as customer obsession
as opposed to competitor obsession and I
have seen over and over again companies
talk about that their customer focused
but really when I pay close attention to
them I believe they are competitor
focused and that's just a completely
different mentality by the way
competitor focus can work but I don't
think it works in the long run as well
as customer focus for one thing once
you're the leader if your whole culture
is competitor obsessed it's kind of hard
to stay energized and motivated if
you're out in front whereas customers
are always unsatisfied they're always
discontent they always want more and so
no matter how far you get out there in
front of your competitors you're still
behind your customers so they're always
pulling you along so customer obsession
is a deep principle that underlies
everything we do another one is
eagerness to invent so we love to
pioneer and when we have done by the way
whenever we have tried to do something
in a kind of meat to fashion we have
failed at it we need to have something
that is differentiated unique something
that customers are going to like that
we're kind of leading with so that's
another element that works for us and
then another one is long term
thinking we are willing to to take some
time and be patient with our business
initiatives and that runs through
everything so a lot of our competitors
might have two to three year kind of
timeframe so we might have more of a
five to seven year sort of timeframe and
then the last one operational excellence
so literally you know how do you have
high standards around you know
identifying defects fixing defects at
the root all those kinds of things that
lead to what I think also can be in a
simpler way just eat it as
professionalism that you want to do
things right just for the Ritz sake I'm
doing them right values aren't created
they're discovered and they're
discovered through a consultation with
the parts of yourself that you're not
conscious of that you're not fully
conscious of that aren't articulated
that aren't fully articulated elements
of your primary personality you have to
discover what your values are and you're
informed about that well partly by other
people who will object if your values
aren't appropriate but certainly by a
dialogue with yourself and with your
conscience that's that's a very
important thing to know it's part of the
reason why I think that you need to tell
the truth because you're forced to
negotiate with yourself to operate
properly in the world and if you've
warped yourself let's say or some
elements of yourself by engaging in self
deception and lies and and you're not
now because of that you're not who you
could be and you don't live in the world
as you should live in it then when you
discuss with yourself what your value
should be it will be as if you're
discussing it with someone that you
can't trust and that's that's not good
like you you can't afford that life is
difficult and it contains many pitfalls
and unless you're careful and you search
your cellphone properly and you aim high
and walk on the straight and narrow path
you don't have a hope of understanding
where you should be and at what time
when
the crisis hits and the crisis will hit
let's say I'm just really superficial
and I value money more than anything
like I've got like a fleet of yachts and
it's it's all I care about you know and
then something happens in my life and I
realize that that's pretty superficial I
should like grow up a bit and you know
value something else and it's not as
simple as just deciding like we've all
had that experience in our lives where
we wish we cared about something that we
don't or vice-versa we wish we didn't
care about something that we do and you
can't just stop and so the process that
I described in the book is that
essentially before you can commit to a
new value you kind of have to like try
them on like like it's like going
through a store and trying on a bunch of
pairs of clothes and the way you try on
a new value is you need to sit down and
visualize and you can even write it out
if you want but it's like let's say all
I care about is my fleet of boats and
and I want to try on a new value like
charity or something I have to sit down
and start asking myself what would it
mean for my life what would it mean for
me as a person if I didn't value those
boats anymore and that's a very hard
question it really it messes us up
because we realized that a lot of our
relationships would probably fall apart
a lot of our business commitments would
probably fall apart a lot of our
understanding of ourselves
would be shaken up or questioned and
it's a very difficult thing to ask and
so you know most of the times when you
see visualization taught in the
self-help industry it's like they take a
guy who wants a fleet of boats and they
say visualize a fleet of boats now go
get it and it's like no no what you need
to do is think a guy who wants a fleet
of boats and say visualize not wanting a
fleet of boats what would that say about
you who would you be if that thing you
always desired was not your desire
anymore
ow
my experience has been with
make bad choices and then you'll learn
how to make money
with us when I changed careers I was
never changed into something for money I
was changed into something I love
right and that to me that's really the
only way to keep the passion if you have
two choices one is on a piano
and another way
can make more money bullying but you
love playing the piano
you gotta play the piano it's like
you'll tear yourself apart if you're not
doing the thing
life
you know what it is right right now
there's something that you love more
than everything whatever it is it's
crazy what does human value money oh yes
very important sometimes I jokingly is
it telling the Buddhist audience
particularly Tibetan you usually use you
to cite one Tibetan special sort of
mantra that is Oh money payment home so
we recite sometimes to be little bit a
hurry then you see we decide on money
pay more money then money or money money
money money so that sounds looks like
money money money money money right so
maybe dollar money dollar money or found
money pawn money like that
so buddy of course what I think value
and of course all these external versus
the facilities there's a value of the
things good but all these
provide physical comfort not mental
comfort if you have plenty of money then
some kind of satisfaction in the leather
oh I have a lot of money that solution
actually because we notice among the
Linnaean plenty of money but as a person
very unhappy person whatever worry
whatever anxiety lot of suspicion lot of
jealousy as a person money failed to
bring in a piece pilgrim money bring
more suspicion more uncomfortable more
worried anyone who truly believe if you
have money everything can't solve
everything then you get rid of the
personal satisfaction decided dilution
money can bring some friend but that
essentially friend of money not freedom
being yourself your photo go like that
you become richer literature you found
more friends then when your orcid a your
fortune goes like that then these
friends also I think disappear
even you want to telephone they may not
answer it is the solely spend are not
changing your friend but a fairly old
money my parents worked hard to pay the
bills and to keep a roof over our heads
but even though my parents couldn't give
us material things they gave us
something much more precious they gave
me and my brother strong values they
taught us to treat others with dignity
and respect they taught us to push for
excellence in every single thing we did
they taught us to be humble and to be
grateful for everything we had they
taught us to put every last bit of
effort into our education and to take
pride in our work they taught us that
our circumstances didn't define us and
that if we believed in ourselves if we
made the most of every single
opportunity we could build our own
destinies and accomplish anything we put
our minds to I had I had this idea that
I was going to you know buy and sell
crash cars right so I'll buy two five
thousand put twenty five hundred into it
and then sell it at ten thousand it's
simple and if you put the math together
I was gonna do that every month and then
they would start compounding in two
three years I was gonna be a Dylan heir
yeah pretty much simple I had it all
planned out with that girl and I love I
love joking saying mike tyson's you know
theory is uh you know everybody has a
plan until I get punched in the face and
life will punch you in the face I pretty
much got punched in the face price six
months into it and then I found myself
working a Red Lobster with none of that
money because I was trying to do it for
money yeah you know um I hate I really
hate working on cars cuz I can't work on
them my hands are really buttery so my
hands feel like veal
I'm not supposed to work on a car man
and I'm thinking you know you know that
about yourself though I love
you know well I do it myself after the
first transmission you know crush my
foot and I really like like you know
what I think I think hats are better you
know so but again you know a lot of
people out there chasing their dream but
their dream is to just be rich and
that's not a dream
you know if you if you if you if you try
to go out and meet just make money for
the purpose of making money first of all
you could end up in the wrong place
due to it you could be miserable and
then when you get it if you don't have
no goal on why you were trying to
achieve this goal you feel unfulfilled
the first thing that you have to ask is
what are your highest values so for me
for example my number one highest value
is God my number two values my health my
number three values my family a number
four value is contribution to the lives
of others moment number v value is fun
so every day when I wake up I think
about what am i doing today to connect
with God for me yes for me it doesn't
have to be and you know it's not
religious it's just for me then what do
I need to do every day to make sure that
I'm healthy what I need to do every day
to make sure that my family and my dear
close friends are a part of my family
that I have the relationship that's rich
then contribution how do I use my my
passion my gifts my my stories my things
I've not done well things I have done
how do I share that with the world and
in doing that I feel good and then I
have to have fun and so if I do those
five things every day then at the end of
every day I've had a great day and if
you have a lot of great days then you
end up with a really great life and that
doesn't mean that you don't have ups and
downs and things that don't work and
trouble that happens and things that
come up but if you keep your focus on
what's important then the rest of the
stuff is really inconsequential and
there isn't a hundred different things
you have to do there's two or three
things in each one of the areas that's
important to you that when you do those
every day you're so far ahead of the
I mentioned earlier the work built to
last was very interesting we were
studying enduring great companies in
contrast to others went back recently
and realized we selected the study set
for that study in 1989 two decades ago
all 18 of the built to last companies
are still standalone independent and
almost all of them very successful
companies today if you took a random
sample of large publicly traded
companies 20 years ago what are the
probabilities that all eighteen in your
random sample would be standalone
independent and largely successful today
the number is less that the percentage
is about 0.02 percent probability not
only that 15 of the 18 built to last
companies lived through the 1930s
depression what do they teach us what
has enabled them to have that what did
we find that separated them and what we
found is that what really separated was
not necessarily that they had smarter
strategies although they often did or
that they were sort of more financially
savvy although they often were it was
because they were found at first and
foremost and built always on a
rock-solid set of core values that are
not open for negotiation and if you look
at what gave them the reason to struggle
the reason to fight the reason to endure
it wasn't strategic it was values if you
think about a retail environment where
people are buying things in a retail
environment the retailer has a whole
bunch of control they choose the
products they design the store or the
catalog if they train the salespeople
they control the experience and if
there's a problem with a sale you know
with the salesperson they retrain and so
on and so forth at eBay our customers
experience is based on how one customer
interacts with another customer ok and
you can't control customer behavior so
the only thing you can do is have a
certain set of values that you encourage
people to adopt and the only way your
customers are going to adopt those
is if they see that you're living those
values as well so when I say that I
believe people are basically good it's
because I believe people are basically
good I mean it's not something that I
came up with for eBay and if I say that
you should treat people with the benefit
of the doubt it's because I believe in
that is a way of life and we have to do
it internally at eBay at the company as
well because if we don't then eventually
that seeps through and customers will
see that and that will harm our business
because you know we can't control
customer behavior so our business is
based on that for the first 50 years of
my life omission I thought that my life
was about me I had the attitude of a 10
year old or a 9 year old or a 6 year old
but I had that attitude when I was 29 or
39 I just you know I thought that wasn't
a bad person I'm not trying to paint
myself is this horrible individual but I
was fairly self-centered I was looking
at my own career my own goals my old
objectives my old needs my old wants my
old desires I tried to be even-handed
about it if somebody helped me out I
tried to give back if I could and all
those things that were taught to do but
basically my life was focused on me
fascinatingly even though my life was
focused on me virtually all the time my
life wasn't working I really had at some
point in my life I really got oh gosh I
can't seem to find happiness that lasts
more than a little while like I can't
seem to find success that lasts was it a
little while everything is so ephemeral
it just comes in and goes out comes in
and goes out I never seem to get
anywhere to the top of the mountain when
when is to struggle over this what I was
experiencing when I had my first
conversation with God so that's the
context that's the background why I was
given that wisdom because I asked God
okay obviously there's something here I
don't understand
I listen to what my daddy told me and
listen to what my mommy told me I listen
to what my religion told me I listen to
what my culture told me but there's some
missing data I felt that there was just
some information that was missing so I
said to God what is it what is it that I
don't understand here the understanding
of which would change everything God
said to be Neal it's really very simple
and then she said what you just said
here Neal your life is not about you
your life is about everyone else whose
life you touch and the way in which you
touch it and I said well I don't
understand they were supposed to give up
everything that I ever wanted her
desired her hoped for give up all of my
goals all of my objectives and she said
no no no I didn't say that I didn't say
that
you don't have to set aside all of your
goals set aside all of your objectives
set aside all of the things to do all of
your desires no I didn't say that
but it's about achieving them working
toward them moving toward them in a
whole different way for a whole
different reason if you're doing those
things to enrich the lives of everyone
whose life you touch watch the world
fall in on you with Wonder and joy and
celebration but if you're doing those
things together
to gather gather gather get kid can't
have more have more have more could you
just like you know you just want to get
as much as you can for yourself if
that's your prime motivation you're
gonna be struggling every day for the
rest of your life
when Asher made I love college it was in
the basement of this house I was renting
in this craphole that like bred rats
everywhere he's called the green house
because truth is he was smoking so much
weed done it but that night he wasn't
smoked weeks never smoking when Justin
was around but he recorded I love
college and Justin actually was in the
studio hmm he was a wood studio it's
like a little crap room in the basement
you know my budding engineering but we
all kind of came up together and there's
this really great picture of me Asher
and Justin on the front porch of that
house and no one knew Justin was I mean
there's videos of Asher I mean with
Ludacris and everyone's hyped because
Asher and Ludacris are in the same room
and they don't notice there's this
little kid sitting behind us show ins
Justin so and he was 12 when this he was
at that time
13:14 when you first had a move - he was
13 when I haven't move I found when he
was here the videos he was 12 yeah but
he you know just the whole adventure to
kind of you you respect everything so
much more and it also reminds you when
you get money that tomorrow isn't
promised yeah and you value everything
you know because you know what it's like
to be a big promoter and have all kinds
of money and then literally be paying
for pizza would change because you spent
it all trying to make it now I've got a
special bonus clip that I think you're
gonna enjoy but before that it's time
for the best life 30 questions of the
day it's not enough to just watch a
video you have to do something so pull
out your worksheets and answer these
questions and if you don't have the
worksheets and you want them for free
check out the link in the description
below question number one what is your
most important core value and why number
two where are you living in consistently
with your core value and number three
what steps will you take the change to
match your core value to your life and
if you are doing the best live 30
challenge with me put a hashtag best
live 30 down the comments below so we
can celebrate with you if you don't get
this right your business will fail it's
not just about what you love doing in
the skillsets you have it's about having
similar core values as the people that
you bring on board you need to know what
your who is you need to know what you
stand for
as a human being you need to know what
your mission is and bring people on
board who have similar core values this
is where so many entrepreneurs fail if
you only do a self-assessment and say
well I'm good at this I'm gonna be the
technician I'm gonna be the artist I'm
gonna be the coder I'm gonna be the one
doing all of the actual work and I need
to partner up with somebody who's a
business person who's gonna be doing the
deals in the media and raising the
capital and talking to investors and
doing the sales pitches it's not enough
to say well I'm good at this and you're
good at this so let's get together and
that's what so many people do that's why
so many business partnerships fail
because you're just looking at it on
paper you just see well they have the
skill sets I don't have great let's work
together boom we're in business
and often times entrepreneurs will then
say hey Walt let's do 50/50 right
you're bringing this I'm moving there so
here we go 50/50 partnership and for
those who've been through it before you
know how much of a disaster that can be
because everything looks good on paper
but you can't make a decision just based
off of paper it's like going to a dating
website
and put it in your ideal person and then
deciding to marry that person without
ever going on a date
it's about core values why do things
fall apart because you don't share the
same core values and a lot of times you
need to know what your own core value is
to start with so you figure out your one
word your most important core value
that's the starting point you have to
figure it out it may well serve you
not just for your business but for any
relationship for life this is what you
stand for is a human and then you want
to attract people who not just have the
skill set in the desire but the same
core value because you know what the
skill set is actually easier to teach
than the core value to make somebody
change their beliefs I don't know how to
do it it's crazy it's it's ridiculous
to give somebody a new skill set it's
way easier to teach if you want to join
the best live thirty challenge click the
link right here below me or if you want
some more videos to dive deeper into
your core values check out the playlist
right there next to me continue to
believe and I'll see you there